mr. save stereo you will be one of the
speakers at the next conference on the
14th of November and sides of waiting
for the park areas
my question to you is what maybe also
looking at your life experience what can
you tell us about garbage
but it will ask you today about my
personal experience
I have seen the arrival of barbarians
and then educated later in June 41
Operation Barbarossa is touted under my
window in this world
punch down I found
I think that the Bible isn't like you I
may have experienced my Johnson was
probably the highest stage of barbarism
laughing well then that's easily has
happened so this is the of course to the
fact that I have decided to
I am working so life and history history
and life coming together in my my
personal experience that season was
founded basically of the idea of active
superiority and this I believe to be the
world things that could happen to it
let's religion why I'm doing what
but not only my scientific weapon
because let's live life into it
but this is also problems in this
country and he some very complete
then the political aspect
Nazism in here you mention your
what do you think causes these feelings
differences
because then
the solution you know are these other
weaknesses of the rest of one of the
weaknesses
founder he's denying especially power of
reason the idea but is something
stronger
than Russia that he's Russian I think
that anti rationally you saw people in
our lives and our sickness as with our
history
we'll have our grasshopper gills so
continuing in defending the same have
the same rights and should be brought to
the same level of culture of
civilization and good life as we
experience it in Western Europe
I think that this is basically what
prevents heart and will prevent us in
the future from becoming to gain victims
of values pathology history is different
every time
but understanding ventures for returning
to another former power I have a
question the living under nurse ISM how
did you survive during World War two
what was your survival how did I survive
way very reason beside myself so first
of all because
he had my clothes Krishna the Catholics
not by Jews and Catholics I have to
thank and without their hand I would
have not survived I think every Jew who
survived in Europe survived because you
have to helping somebody
this one probably removes the greatest
aspect of humanity people helping other
people just because people were
persecuted and this was based on idea
but how people have the same religious
people people who believe in God would
say that God has created all of us I am
NOT a believer I am not religious I will
say that all people and we say because
we are rational teens and they have the
same rights and these rights should be
protected all over the world and in any
situation
when you were living here in Jerusalem
somebody attacked you why well it was a
few years ago I was and stealin and
probably will be until the end of my
life we consider great enemies logic
colonialism all the territories of the
occupied territories because I'm I'm
considered by some people as some kinds
of intellectual simple of all that this
world you choose and what is wrong
because I mean that we believe in the
quality of Jews and Arabs and we believe
that everybody has the same rights and
all the people have the same right
will he live ideally the universal right
and because I believe in universal right
I do not accept my we ever Jews have
different rights from ours from occupied
Palestinian so this idea of equality of
all people is
the basic element is my political
philosophy g1 of Technology in New
Jersey